if you're a fan of Succession then you
know it's your obsession if you haven't
watched it yet you need to starting
Sunday at 9:00 Eastern Time all you need
to catch up also on HBO go because
succession is on HBO and it is nominated
for five Emmy Awards including Best
Drama this Sunday Alan Rock part of
succession and it's fantastic cast back
here on the Rich Eisen show good to see
you sir to see you that theme is fun and
haunting right just one you just wrote l
just won the Academy Award I met kadmiel
in the Emmy excuse me for jumping gun on
that yeah yeah never know you don't know
and and the thing is I I say Best Drama
but I will say this no other hour-long
show makes me laugh as hard and often as
succession I'm laughing throughout the
entire episode it's it's fun to laugh at
damaged rich people yeah
it's therapeutic well yeah and you could
be I mean in this saying a lot you could
be the most damaged of them all I mean
there's there's a lot I mean I can I
should I should I should say obviously
your character yeah I should say you
know there are some other your siblings
are pretty damn bro yeah so is the dad
yeah Connors missing some chips he's
missing she doesn't he doesn't have all
the pieces to the puzzle and you are
preparing to your characters preparing
to run for president yeah knocking real
hard on that door about a presidential
run but you know Connor has no he has no
concept of what he's doing his no no
he's not in touch with reality which
means it when he could know an obscenely
wealthy unqualified person with
psycho-emotional challenges he might win
he could actually win now you were
telling Chris in the commercial break
and you told me back backstage you have
not watched season two yet you have not
seen an episode no no nope just not a
frame I my wife is busy right now she's
working in Europe and will be going back
and forth she's actually commuting yes
and the kids not gonna go meet up with
her in Spain and then when she's done
and we're back home here then we'll
binge it together you just go straight
episode
one through lives just as much as we can
handle at any given sitting it's so much
fun I gotta tell you Alan it is a
rip-roaring amount of fun good times I
wish I could ask you what your favorite
line is because so many of them are not
safe for well yeah we can't say in here
well I mean the one that we just saw in
the in the clip where you're at a
funeral for a family friend right yeah
Lester yeah but your girlfriend called
her called him Momo right because why is
that again it was a joke with the old
man in his crowd Moe Lester right Moe
Lester because he had he had he had some
problems he was a criminal basically he
was he was a bad guy right and then your
opening line of your eulogy was what was
that again I don't know I don't want us
inside did I oh yeah yeah do something
along the lines of Lester touched all of
us oh yeah yeah while he was thinking of
you know jokingly was like Lester
touched all of us he touched all of us
deep inside it's amazing but it is it is
it is a show that is worth everybody's
everybody's time Thanks and it's on at
9:00 9:00 Eastern on on Sunday nights
and you'll be part as the whole cast
getting together to go to the Emmys on
Sunday night hearing Calkins wife jazz
just had a baby girl okay Kinzie okay so
they will they will not he will not be
there and Brian Cox is starring his LBJ
in a play on Broadway so he will not be
there and then I guess maybe everybody
else my wife Susie who I'll bring up now
because you have met her sent me a tweet
a video of Brian Cox teaching a toddler
Shakespeare that is one of the greatest
videos I've seen and I'd love yeah I
mean what is it like being on the set
with with him Alan he's just like the
rest of us you know he's just you know
he's just a bundle of neuroses he's just
like yeah he's like any other actor you
know he just happens to be a great one
he is terrific yeah yeah wonderful guy
right and this is true with a lot of
dramatic actors is between techs they're
just bananas
because they have to let it all go right
now so he's in between takes he's he's a
little bit silly well I mean just
wonderful there is scenes where he was
throwing meats on the floor episodes ago
he's actually throwing hot dogs at the
war on the floor so okay now where you
met my wife on a plane yes so I was
flying back and forth to New York to do
the show right and waiting to go on and
this is there's a whole story and
there's a very tall young man very tall
sort of military bearing looks like he
could have been in the military and he's
got a service animal who happens to be a
pitbull okay but cute pitbull like PD
from the little rascals right make sure
and then another woman shows up with a
dog that's about the size of a sandwich
hmm and then she says oh my god is your
dog gonna eat my dog and then the guy
got very upset he's like why would you
say such a thing why use a very gentle
dog and then another guy interjects
himself and it's like hey man back off
you're acting like a douche bag
wow it's like people are gonna start
throwing hands or whatever so anyway
then I go on board and then your wife
comes in sits next to me and then we see
the very tall man walk by with the
pitbull wife just says Oh dogs on planes
not a fan my wife she said dogs on
planes not a fan you know oh and so then
she told me that so we you know and then
I found out that she was married to you
I did that job you know and then she
told me that the woman with a little
sandwich dog yeah went to the counter
and said that she was traumatized by the
incident and she needed to be put on
another plane and needed to be upgraded
so she was that lady she was that lady
right that's probably what Suzy was not
a fan of you know because you make these
dogs I mean I thought she was probably
gonna intervene on behalf of the guy
with the pit bull
oh well well and anyway so we get off
the plane and there's cops like real
cops with real guns and I was like oh
it's on it's on are you serious yeah and
then I went down to baggage and who do I
see but the very tall man with the pit
bull hmm and I'm like what happened he
said the other guy kept doing this
during the flight and started talking a
lot of trash drinking yeah he was like
pounding him back and I guess he was
like thinking would you do
think I can kick your ass you know that
kind of he went there and so that very
tall guy with the big dog was actually
very sweet and anyway so that was that
story and I met your wife then you met
my wife Wow
there you go white house light how about
them apples yeah you know when you get
off a plane and there's people waiting
there with guns drawn or something like
the or or police they're not looking at
me
notices glad they're not looking at you
Alan ruck Iran the Rich Eisen show what
we're do you have any mementos from
Ferris Bueller anywhere in your
possession anything at all I have some
little they were some part of the
marketing campaign was I'm doing over
here it's all a little button that said
FB do okay like something they're gonna
hand out to kids so it's just some
little piece so that's it yeah yeah you
wondering if I had the jurors yes yes
yeah no no no that that belonged to
Western costume company call most part
of Paramount Pictures at the time and
Marilyn Vance the one full costume
designer so not no sunglasses no I mean
what do you think I was pretty sick of
wearing that you know I mean I was in
the same outfit for a couple of months I
was I was done I bet I mean we're
showing the photographs if that's me of
you up there I mean looking so damn
young but you were the oldest on the
color didn't you tell us that the last
time how old were you I was 29 I had
just turned 29 Allan rock 29 and good
and you passed for a high school I got
away with it I got away with it but that
was it you see that was my swan song as
a team does he well I mean could you
turn 30 I turned 30 movie came out in
turn 30 yeah what do you think of when
you see when you see that photograph
right there
that a lot of time has passed no courage
no kidding yeah yeah I mean I had a
really good time working on that show
and I had fun working with Broderick
we'd done a play together before that we
right house was a really nice time in my
life I'm in Spin City you spent some
time on that set as yeah yeah did six
seasons that's what a fun show that was
yeah you got a good Richard kind story
anybody who's ever come across Richard
Caan has got a great Richard Khan store
just you know Richard does something
that I love is he has no compunctions
about walking up to the most famous
person in the room and going hi rich
kind hi you know and you know if Jesus
were here he go hi mr. Christ rich kinda
fan you know he would cuz he just
doesn't hold himself back and so I
actually admire that you know he is you
know I've come across him and and
anybody I'm God and I do and he's a
terrific golfer but he's a terrific
golfer he'll sit and everybody's ever
met him does an imitation of the actor
Richard kind a mutual friend of ours
called him up the other day when he
arrived in New York just to see if
Richard could have lunch yeah and
Richard yes from where are you and he
was sitting in his car waiting for
another 40 minutes to the point where
the car would be legal to leave there
for two more days yeah cents of every
dollar he's ever made when we were on
Spin City and we'd be like oh I gotta
get uptown I gotta get uptown I'm gonna
be late yeah you know oh where can I get
a taxi he'd say why don't you take the
bus you know cuz he's just he's that guy
he's frugal he's a frugal dude he is a
frugal dude yeah well look man thanks
for coming on congratulations again this
this show has been renewed for a third
season yep whose succession up against
this Sunday do you have the list of the
the it's a deep bench it's a lengthy
list
what's Game of Thrones isn't it oh boy
yeah this is us this is us
yep okay I don't know there's a lot it's
a very very deep lot a lot of good shows
out there okay and but this is just as
good as any other man Thanks so
congratulations on that
he plays Connor ROI on succession every
single Sunday at 9:00 Eastern Time on
HBO thanks for thanks for coming on my
pleasure that's Alan ruck right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app